okay proposition number three it's okay
to appropriate the work of artists okay
I know this one's gonna get me in
trouble and I'll qualify it but but I
think that if you kind of come back to
this model like artists aren't really
meant to participate in the market in
the first place I mean maybe you sell
some works
I'm sure that's that's part of the
market most are just have a lot of
trouble making it living doing that I
mean the markets not really there to
support artists in the first place and I
want to give you one example James
Turrell so for those of you that aren't
familiar with James Terrell's work he is
a like a an amazing artist that works
with light and space you ever seen any
of this installations you go there and
you feel the sense of like sublime sort
of spiritual at peace with the world and
and just works with your perception in
such ways that it's just somehow magical
he's been doing this work for years and
years and he's sort of pioneered that
area and this is the video by Drake
called hotline bling which came out last
year and if you look at this video
you'll see that it really looks a lot
like James Terrell's work right like
changing life sculpture was sort of
minimal one of the folks at
Hyperallergic did a shot by shot
analysis of some of Drake's work and and
Terrell's work and so on the top you see
Drake's Drake's you know installation on
this video work in the video and then to
Rawls installations below and Drake was
asked about this and and he actually
said you know it actually said she said
you're a big influence yeah you know I
with Terrell if he was a big
influence on me and then they asked
Terrell about it and Terrell said you
know well he honored my work you know I
actually enjoyed it I got a lot more
attention since he got involved and so
so I kind of come back to this
proposition and that's why I called a
proposition and not a statement it's
okay to appropriate the work of artists
under a few conditions first of all you
need to recontextualize the work which i
believe is what dick Drake did he
presented a music video the music kind
of matched the form that he was working
with he reshot it so reaching
contextualizing work doesn't mean going
on someone's website and taking the JPEG
off there and printing out a quilt and
selling on Alibaba that's not really
recontextualizing that's just stealing
it all so I just need to have some sort
of funding model right so like taking
work and appropriating from some artists
that's not even how doesn't mean
something sort of living to make their
work and it's doing that on the side
that's not
really fair to the artist but if they
had funding behind them then they could
participate in this kind of economy
where they could let their ideas go more
freely and finally give them some sort
of nod of credit and that is important
not only to acknowledge the artist but
also to dispel this creator myth that
this idea that we somehow get amazing
ideas from our own head and they're not
born from anywhere else to just
acknowledge this and create a lineage of
thought and culture and I think that
kind of idea that that I'm kind of
mining here or thinking about is that
artists have need to have this expanse
of time and if they're working with the
exigencies the market and thinking about
how to make it living all the time they
don't have time to really think about
those long-term kind of thoughts and to
work in this artistic direction they're
much more concerned with the immediate
how to saw my work how to find funding
and don't have that expanse of space to
be creative
[Music]